[Music]
Don't make a face like that I'm afraid you'll be pulled back Your Majesty I hope you're well Your
Majesty I hope you're doing well The trip is still good, so
give me your strength  I
miss you
so much Goddess Aristia I wanted to see you one last time.
Without your five senses, it would have been
impossible for you to create the Kingdom of Silber in a single generation. The reason why you
revealed your photos to your demons and came to
be called the King of Heroes is because
your heart is straight.  I'm
sure your eyes are clear.If you say so,
this old man
has a flower.Therefore,
today, I would like to reward you
for your great achievements.Do you
have any wishes?  If there is anything I can do, I'll grant it.I wonder if it's
anything.I
hope I'll be reborn once more.My
life has been
devoted only to my country and people.I
have no regrets about that, but if I become
king
If you had devoted your whole life to your own sake,
how much would that power
have been?  I'm looking forward to that
[music] Look, Takamura,
Inglis is terrified Is
this really
reincarnated?
[Music] I'm sure you
'll be a pretty woman in the future
[Music]
Engraved
In this world where I live for myself, I'll
reach out my hand
[Music] There's
no radish I
wish so much I
touched the future I believed in and
stood up  Overlooking the journey, where I
belong,
repainting the joy This is a
story that will begin once I put my heart to the end I'm aiming
[music]
To the world [
music] - Well,
baby fruit doesn't tremble the sword,
but
even if you're reborn, the goddess' blessing will live on
[Music]
Ether is the source of all things in this world.
Everything in the world is made up of Ether.  In
other words, it is the
power of God.In my previous
life, I only learned the basics of how to use the ether.  I'm
curious,
run away as a Christian, where are you floating?  May
you be a worthy monster The
children
Rafael is watching Rafinia
Now hurry up
Mother I'm glad you're
okay Raphael Rafinia is a good girl
Let's wait for the
magic stone gun to be driven away.
[Music] It's
only natural to be afraid For the sake of those children's futures, it
would be nice if they could come in a world where there's no such thing as an invertebrate, but that's a problem.  All
right, I'm not afraid,
Chris. It's
frustrating. Even though
I've already received the runes, the only thing I'm
looking at here is the
weapon artifacts used to fight demon oil.
Engraved into my body,
that didn't exist in my previous life
Raphael Your rune is a special express in. It can
only be given to those who are truly chosen and who can become the hopes of the people on earth.
Even if you abandon everyone in this place,
you have to live.
But
magic oil moves quite agile Don't throw it away
[Applause]
Wait a minute
[Music] Even the
important people in front of you can't be saved, and
many people can't be helped.  It's
not something that people tell you to become That's what you'll be
called by your own will and deeds It's a
shame to let a child die in a place like
this I've
decided to live this life for myself That's
why I'm interested in becoming a hero  No,
but I'm not
afraid to lend a hand to someone who has that talent.  I
think it's just an illusion,
but I'm sure I'll be
fine with just the baby.  It's an
interesting story because he
can destroy time all by himself. I'll try to be
able to beat Prisman. That hobby.
Music]
Christian You
really like mirrors, don't
you
think?  I
can't believe we're both 5 years old What kind of education do you get like
this
?
[Music]
Yes,
please.  The talent of the listed
[music]
department
is outstanding. Thank you.
Excuse me
[music] I'm asking for your
help today Today's swordsmanship match will be
held.  My
brother said
this
is my son Roll. My name is
Rahl.
So,
at first, the Knights had a landslide victory with
him alone, but when he came out, the tide changed.
Shine, your
attitude suddenly grew bigger.
I was wearing a cat.  But perhaps that child has an
extraordinary way of keeping a distance. Are you
serious?  It is
magic that causes the phenomenon of the top of the world.It
is a technique of paralysis that blocks the
movement of the opponent who puts it in your field of vision.
I
seem to have misplaced my knowledge and sensibility about magic somewhere. Thank you, Chris.  It's a
girl.
I'll meet you
next time.It's an honor to be able to fight the future Holy Knight.
I don't know if it's
better, but
something's wrong. Everyone's movement is slow.
Even if I don't understand it, it's
probably best to just hint at it.
Until then,
Rahl-kun won.
As expected of the future Holy Knight, Ryoko-sama is on a
different level than the other kiss-samas.
Is this country okay
?
No, I
'll reveal what you're doing secretly But what am
I doing
?  That's
unreasonable, Chris, I'm
drunk.
Even so, I'm my father's daughter. I
have to protect the honor of the Knights Order.
First of all,
do
your best.This level of magic will naturally make you infertile if you
use ether.If you use ether, you
can definitely win, but that's
boring.
[Music] I
was able to do it when I was young in my previous life, but now it's a
great opportunity to put my current skills to the test
[Music] [
Music]
[Music] Were there
vibrations in our house
?
[Music]
Thank you for coming in.
[Music] It was amazing Thank you.
What [
Music] It
was a pretty good fight.
Music]
I'm ready to go out No matter what I wear, I
don't need luggage other than self-confidence Self-Hazuki club My favorite crossing
It doesn't have to be sparkling, it does
n't have to be glamorous,
forget about the big
love
[music]